PROFESSOR: OK, let us resume.
I had no idea how many people
would be here today, and I
think I made 25 copies
of the handout.
And I see 25 names
on the list.
And that means that two
people did not get
a copy of the syllabus.
Does anybody need a copy?
That's strange.
OK.
All right.
We covered some introductory
material, and I think we've
covered enough that you
can do a problem set.
So it gives me great pleasure
to hand out
problem set number one.
OK, you can think about that.
It is the sort of problem that
will either take you two
minutes or two hours
or infinity.
So don't spend too much time on
it, but I would like you to
put your name on it and turn it
in either at the end of the
hour or next time so I can
make comments if there's
something that's mostly right
but not quite right.
Let's return to these three
simple patterns that we put on
the blackboard.
And let me make another
point about symmetry.
The people who sensed that this
pattern and the one on
the bottom were the same because
they had the same
motif in them, that they had
the same rectangle with one
concave side.
And I drew a mirror line in here
because that locus, when
I review this is a reflection
from left to right, left the
motif, as well as the entire
pattern, unchanged upon making
that transformation.
Is there not also a
mirror line there?
Worked for this motif.
Why not for this motif?
Well, the answer is no, that
this is not a mirror line
because the symmetry
transformations acts on
everything, and not just one
little bit of space.
And if I would take this
chain of objects that's
translationally periodic with
a translation running this
way, and I reflected that, I
should have another chain
running like this.
So the direction of the
translation vector is not left
invariant by this reflection.
So the conclusion here, and it's
a subtle one, matter of
definition, almost, is that
the transformation, the
symmetry transformation, if
it's to be a symmetry
transformation, acts on all of
the space, and not just on one
local domain.
So let me give you an example
of a pattern that doesn't
involve translational
periodicity.
So let me try to make a star
as carefully as I can.
What sort of symmetric does that
have, or would it have
had I drawn it more perfectly?
Well, that would be a five-fold
rotation axis in the
middle because I could
rotate through one
fifth of the circle.
And any of those rotations twice
or three times, or just
2 pi over five, would be
something that maps the
pattern into congruence
with itself.
There are also mirror lines that
go from one tip of the
star to the other end.
So that is an example of a
pattern, non-periodic, but one
that has five-fold rotational
symmetry and mirror symmetry.
Now, if I put that star in a
box and ask, what is the
symmetry of that space?
There's only one operation which
is common to the star
and to the enclosing rectangle,
and that's this
mirror plane.
So the symmetry acts not just
on one little part of the
space, but it has to leave
everything invariant.
So in that sense, going to this
pattern here, this is not
a mirror plane because it
doesn't leave the entire
pattern invariant.
That plane would reflect this
one up to here, and we don't
have anything there.
So the space is not
left invariant.
One further definition.
We defined what we mean when
we say a space or an object
has symmetry.
We said an object or a space
possesses symmetry when there
is an operation, or set of
operations, that maps the
space or the object into
congruence with itself.
Let me make another definition,
and that a
symmetry element--
another bit of terminology--
is the locus of points that's
left unmoved by the operation.
Left unmoved or left
invariant.
So for some specific examples,
this vertical line is a locus
which is left invariant by
either the five-fold rotation
or any of the mirror planes
passing through the points
that would be true
of the star.
So for the star, these are
all symmetry elements.
For the net combination of the
star and the enclosing
rectangle, the only thing
that leaves a space
invariant is this line.
The locus that's left and moved
is this line, so we
refer to that as
a mirror plane.
Now, these may be seeming
kind of definitions.
Nice to have, but what
use are they?
We will use some of these
definitions to answer a
question which may
seem tricky.
If we do a couple of things in
sequence, for example, what is
the net consequence of doing,
let's say, a rotation combined
with a reflection?
You can answer that question
by saying, what
has been left unmoved?
And that is the locuses of
whatever net transformation
results from a combination
of two or more.
So that, again, is abstract, but
we'll use that later on.
Any question on this?
Let me summarize very quickly
what we have found for two
dimensions.
We found that there are, in a
two-dimensional space, three
kinds of operations.
There is the operation of
translation, which we'll call
by the vector, T, corresponding
to that
transformation.
And there is an operation
of reflection.
And the locus of the plane, in
which the reflection occurs,
we'll call a mirror plane.
And that's a linear locus.
And then, we've seen in these
two patterns here an operation
of rotation.
In particular, in these
two-dimensional patterns, we
saw the rotation
operation A pi.
Now, I would put forth for your
consideration something
that is a profound conclusion.
These are the only single-step
transformations that can exist
in a two-dimensional space.
These are the only ones that
can exist as single-step
operations.
We can view these as operations
that result in a
transformation of coordinates.
And in two dimensions, if we
have some position, x, y, in
the space, what the
transformation of a
translation does is to take x
and add a constant to it.
It takes y and adds, perhaps,
a different constant to it.
Do the operation a second time,
and we'll go to x plus
2a and y plus 2b.
So analytically, we can look at
these symmetry operations
in terms of the transformation
of a representative
coordinate.
If we have a reflection plane,
and let's set up a coordinate
system where this is
y and this is x.
We have an object here at the
location x, y, and we reflect
it across this locus.
It goes to minus x, y, if the
mirror line runs through the
origin and is perpendicular
to x.
So one example of a
transformation by reflection
is that x, y goes
to minus x, y.
And this is a case where the
mirror plane is perpendicular
to x and passes through
the origin.
If we do the operation a second
time, minus x, y would
get mapped back into
x, y again.
It comes back to where
it started from.
So this would be the
first reflection.
This would be the second
reflection.
And we saw in the patterns
an example of one other
transformation.
Let's suppose there was an
operation, A pi, at the
origin, and this was
x, and this was y.
We started out with a
motif here at x, y.
If we rotated that by 180
degrees, it would go down to a
location minus x, minus y.
So the operation of a 180-degree
rotation is going
to analytically correspond to a
transformation of going from
x, y to minus x, minus y.
If we perform it again, it
would go back to x, y.
OK, let's look at this in
more general terms.
In a two-dimensional space,
we've got two dimensions to
diddle with.
We can change the sense
of no coordinate.
That's translation.
We can change the sense
of one coordinate.
That's going to be reflection.
We can change the sense
of both coordinates.
That's going to be a rotation.
That's all we can do.
So these are the three
basic operations in a
two-dimensional space.
I gave you special cases to
make things easy, but
regardless of where the mirror
plane is, parallel to or
perpendicular to an axis or
not, and whether it passes
through the origin or not, a
mirror plane has the operation
of reversing the sense
of one direction.
Just the sense of one direction
that is reversed.
And the rotation, be it a
rotation through 60 degrees or
90 degrees or 180 degrees,
is always taking both
coordinates.
It's making a transformation
of both coordinates.
If you only have two coordinates
with which to
play, that's all you can do.
Let's do some giant
extrapolations.
If we have a strictly
one-dimensional pattern where
there's x and nothing else, than
they're only going to be
two coordinates.
And there are going to be only
two ways we can transform
coordinates.
So in a one-dimensional space,
we can change the sense of no
coordinate, and that's going
to be the operation of
translation, or we can change
the sense of one coordinate,
and that's going to be the
operation of reflection.
No rotation in a one-dimensional
space.
Now, let's extrapolate in
the other direction.
In a three-dimensional space,
the sort that we're going to
be concerned with when we want
to describe the symmetry of
real crystals, you've got three
coordinates to permute.
So it follows then, without
saying what they are, in 3D,
there are going to be four
distinct one-step operations.
And then five dimensions?
Hey, that's a nice thing
about mathematics.
You could play any
game you like.
Not only that, but you
make up the rules.
In a five-dimensional space,
there's going to be six
transformations.
Would we ever want to worry
about five-dimensional
crystallography?
Well, let me hang out a teaser
and not answer the question.
Yeah, there are crystals
for which as many as
six-dimensional symmetries
are necessary.
Wow.
Doesn't that blow the mind?
We'll return to that, and I'll
explain why later on.
Another thing you might ask,
why did I sneak this in?
Why did I say one-step
operation?
Well, it's something we should
worry about, and
unfortunately, we will.
What if you take a motif,
translate it, rotate it around
a couple of times, reflect it,
bounce it up and down three
times, and then put it down?
How do you get from the first
motif to the final one there?
Is there an infinite number
of operations?
Mercifully, no.
The number is small
and very finite.
And we will systematically, in
another week's time, examine
specifically two-step
operations.
And as with many things that
we'll encounter, we might not
be clever enough to
think them up.
But when we start putting
things together into a
synthesis, suddenly we're
going to stumble over
something we don't know how to
explain, and we will have
arrived, like it or not, at a
new feature which we perhaps
hadn't anticipated.
OK, any question
at this point?
All this has been in a way
of general introduction.
We're going to now take things
more slowly and proceed one
step at a time.
I would like to confine our
attention for the moment on
two-dimensional symmetries and
examine the sorts of patterns
that can exist in two
dimensions, fabric patterns,
floor tile, grillwork,
and so on.
And we've seen that, basically,
there seem to be
three operations, three kinds
of operations, translation,
reflection, and rotation.
That's an infinite number of
operations because we are not
specifying whether or not the
rotation angle is restricted
to any particular value.
No reason why it should be.
There are lots of rotational
symmetries that
are absolutely lovely.
But let's build things up.
And I would like to first
look at the operation of
translation, which we've
said a great deal
about to this point.
Translation has magnitude.
It has direction.
So it acts like a vector.
But just like a vector, it
has no unique origin.
Perform the operation twice, and
you have a position that
is two translations removed
from the origin.
Do it three times, you
have a translation
that's three times out.
If a motif sits here, the motif
must sit at the end of
this translation in the same
orientation parallel to itself.
It must exist at the end
of two translations.
And if the operation acts on all
of the space, if we say a
translation is present, we
really imply that there's an
infinite row going to
plus infinity and
back to minus infinity.
And there is a motif hanging
at the terminal
point of every vector.
Now, we can summarize this
periodicity with
a convenient device.
Let's take some fiducial
point and summarize the
translational periodicity by
saying that something that is
hung at one point, either here,
or maybe hung also off
in some other direction relative
to the translation,
that something hung on one of
these points is automatically
reproduced for us
at every point.
So what we have done through
this device is defined
something that is called
a lattice point.
And this is an abstraction of
the translational periodicity.
There is an array of points,
geometric fictions, which we
have constructed.
And we ascribe to this geometric
fiction the property
that anything hung at one of
these points, be it a benzene
ring or be it a Santa Claus on
Christmas wrapping paper, is
understood to be automatically
reproduced at every other one
of these points.
It is this array of fictitious
points that is the proper
designation of what we refer
to as a lattice.
So a lattice is an array of
fictitious points that
summarizes the translational
periodicity of the crystal.
It has a property to repeat
that something hung at a
particular disposition relative
to that point and
with a particular orientation
is understood to be hung at
every other lattice point
in exactly the same way.
So that is a lattice.
And this is one of the
most abused terms in
crystallography.
We talk about the sodium
chloride lattice.
The sodium chloride lattice is
a set of points that are
placed at the corners
of a cube and in the
middle of all the faces.
This is the NaCl lattice.
If I choose to decorate that
lattice with one sodium and
one chlorine, then I have
atoms sitting at
these lattice points.
And that is the sodium
chloride structure.
That is the proper term for
the atomic configuration.
So lattice is a geometrical
term, and it's an abstraction.
Structure is the actual
atomic arrangement.
Now, since I realize already
that I am among friends, I can
confess that I very
often recklessly
abuse the term lattice.
If I talk about lattice energy,
lattice diffusion,
lattice vibration, I'm not
talking about abstract points
bobbling around or something
going through this array of
little points.
I mean, I should talk about
structure diffusion, structure
energy, structure vibration.
But man, that just doesn't
have the established
terminology, and it doesn't
have the zing and music of
something like lattice
vibrations.
So I do it all the time.
Don't tell anybody else that I
said this to you, frankly.
But it's never going
to be stamped out.
But now you perhaps are informed
enough to at least
blush slightly when you talk
about lattice energy or
lattice diffusion, realizing
you're using the term
incorrectly and that you know
better, but everybody else
does it, so you do
the same thing.
So that is the definition
of lattice.
Now, suppose I take this space,
to which I've added a
first translation, and I'll call
it T1, implying that I'm
going to add something
else to this space,
which I'm free to do.
I can put in a second
translational periodicity
because this is a
two-dimensional space.
How do I do this?
And the answer is very carefully
because the second
translation could not go in
the space parallel to the
first one if I put in a second
translation, T2, which is
totally incommensurate
with T1.
The things blow up in my face.
I don't have a lattice.
I will get lattice points
all over the place.
So this is impossible.
So if T1 is not equal to T2,
this space self destructs.
If T1 is a multiple of T2, then
if I say a translation
exists of length T1, and I add a
second translation twice T1.
I've already got those
lattice points.
And that's nothing new.
So if I want to say there's
a second translational
periodicity in the space, the
only thing I can do is pick a
T2 which is not parallel
to T1.
And then this T2 will pick up
everything in the space.
It's going to take these lattice
points and generate
them at equal intervals, T2.
But for that matter, it acts
on everything in the space.
So we could think of this
translation, T2, as moving
this entire infinite string of
lattice points separated by T1
and giving me a whole string
of lattice points.
So now, having taken two
noncollinear translations,
those translations will imply
a two-dimensional space
lattice in which motifs will
be hung at translations nT1
plus mT2 where n, m are integers
that go from minus
infinity to plus infinity.
OK, so this is a two-dimensional
space lattice,
or sometimes it's referred to
by the term a lattice net.
Good term.
It looks like what fishermen
throw in the
water to snag fish.
So it is a net, in terms of
something that we're familiar
with in everyday life.
All right.
So we've specified a space
lattice, but it is a highly
redundant pattern.
We've got a doubly infinite
set of lattice points.
And the unique nature of the
pattern, the structure, is
going to be whatever
is associated
with one lattice point.
So if we specify what's going
on in the vicinity of one
lattice point and establish that
at every other lattice
point, we have the
entire infinite
two-dimensional structure.
So let's ask now, how we can
define the area that is unique
to one lattice point.
And there are several
ways of doing this.
We can specify T1, and
then specify T2.
We'll repeat T1 up to here.
T1 will repeat to T2 over to
here, and we will have defined
the area that is uniquely
associated
with one lattice point.
So if I can tell you what's
going on within the confines
of this parallelogram, then I
have given you the unique part
of what is hung at a lattice
point, and which is reproduced
only by translation.
And this is a very important
construct.
It is something that is referred
to as the unit cell,
or sometimes just
cell for short.
And now we encounter a
curious ambiguity.
T1 and T2 imply an array
of lattice points.
And this particular choice of
T1 and T2 define a cell.
But the reverse is not true.
If I give you--
and what do I want to say?
That a particular lattice
does not specify
a unique unit cell.
Or, stated another way, there
are many different choices for
T1 and T2 that would specify
the same unique area.
I could take this as a T1 prime,
and then I would have a
cell that looks like this.
And that would also define the
area associated with one
lattice point.
It's not clear this oblique
thing with one very long T1
prime would have very much to
commend it, but there are many
ways, many choices, for
T1 and T2, to find
exactly the same lattice.
We could take this as T1, this
as T2, same lattice, same
array of lattice points.
Take this as T1, this as T2,
same array of lattice points.
that's yet another choice.
So there are an infinite
number of translations.
Special name for this, to
introduce a bit of jargon
again, these are very often
called conjugate translations.
So all this is still nothing
more than simple geometry, but
if you invent some fancy words,
you really have to do
that to impress your friends.
Yeah, you had a question here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So you can define magnitude
for T1 and
T2, all those constants.
But you're changing the
directions of T1 and T2, and
you're saying, even though
you're changing those
directions, it's still
the same unit cell?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, provided I have
some new translation like
this one here, which is really
this T1 plus this T2, this
would define a very,
very oblique cell
that looks like this.
But yet, the terminal points
of T1 prime and--
I need a term for this.
I'll call this T2 prime.
The terminal points here are
going to be exactly the same
as the nodes that are
defined here.
So they are two choices for
one in the same lattice.
OK, so the implication of
this is we're going to
have to have rules.
And some of these make
common sense.
You could pick, in a
two-dimensional lattice, some
absolutely ridiculous unit cells
defined in terms of very
long vectors that define a
cell that is a very, very
oblique cell.
So it's the lattice
that's defined by
this translation here.
And the next translation
parallel to this one would go
way up to something like this.
So there's a T1.
There's a T2.
This crazy cell here works.
That's the area that's
associated
with one lattice point.
But clearly, it has absolutely
nothing to
commend this choice.
There's nothing to be gained
by using these long
translations that make
very extreme
intertranslation angles.
Your intuition would say,
why would you want to
do that, you dummy?
Let's take these as the
translations, which is
something I sort of naturally
did all along.
And what are we doing?
We're picking the shortest
translations.
So there's one very
common sense rule.
Another rule, getting a little
bit ahead of the game, but
suppose I examine the lattice
that describes the arrangement
of four floor tiles.
If I take a lattice point
right at the point of
intersection of the joins
between the tiles, that is a
cell that is exactly square.
And it's exactly square because
there's a four-fold
axis in that pattern that leaves
things invariant after
a 90-degree rotation.
So if that's the nature of a
lattice, if it in fact is
constrained because of the
symmetry that is there to have
two translations identical
in length, in fact,
identical in every way.
Pick those as the choice of
the cell to emphasize that
special key feature
of the lattice.
So a second row, which is a
second and final one, is to
pick a T1 and T2 that displays
the symmetry,
if any, of the lattice.
Which introduces us to a feature
which we'll elaborate
much more later on, that the
translational periodicity and
the symmetry of the
lattice are two
things that go together.
That the fact that there is
translational symmetry
drastically reduces the number
of symmetries that you could
have, the fact that there are
symmetries possible for
presence in a lattice restricts
the number of
different kinds of cells.
So these are two aspects of
the pattern, the symmetry
that's in it and its
periodicity.
OK, but these are the only two
rules that we really need to
pick what's called the
standard cell.
Take the shortest translations
that are available to you, and
pick translations that display
the symmetry that may be
present in the lattice.
Any questions or comments?
Any comments?
OK, I think I have time for
one last major point of
discussion.
And what we are going to embark
on now is a process of
synthesis, which will occupy
us for a couple of weeks.
What I'm going to do is start
with a translation.
And this defines an infinite
string of lattice points.
Now, I know that in two
dimensions, I have two kinds
of symmetry operations that are
present, either rotation
or translation.
So now, I'm going to ask the
question, what happens if I
define a lattice, or at least
one translation in a lattice,
and now I add to that lattice an
operation of rotation, OK?
I can do that.
We've seen examples of
translationally periodic
patterns that have rotational
symmetry.
So let me suppose I add to
this space a rotation
operation, A alpha.
And there's no unique origin
to the translation.
There is no unique location
for a lattice point.
So I can put the operation A
alpha in at my designated
lattice point.
Now, if I do that, all hell
breaks loose because now I
have a rotation operation
A alpha.
This has a translation
coming out of it.
That translation will be
repeated up here, an angle
alpha away.
A alpha acts on everything,
so it's going to take this
translation and move it over
here to a location for another
translation.
This is a lattice point.
And this business is going to
go on until it comes around
full circle.
Let me focus my attention
on just one of these
translations, and this will be
this one up here, the one that
is alpha away from
the first in a
counterclockwise direction.
So here sits another
translation, and that means
this is a lattice point.
At this end of the translation,
the same thing is
going to happen.
The operation A alpha is moved
to this location at the end of
the translation.
That means that anything coming
out of this lattice
point must also be repeated at
angular intervals, alpha.
And now I'm going to focus
my attention on
this translation here.
And there will be a translation
that goes up like
this, and this is
a lattice point.
And now, in the words of that
famous musical, there's big
trouble in River City.
Because we started out by saying
that everything in the
space was periodic at an
interval, T, a translational
interval, T.
This is T. This is T.
This is T. Here we
have a lattice point.
This jolly well has to be T as
well, or we've contradicted
the basic assumption of
our construction.
Well, that's over restrictive.
This doesn't have to be T, but
it has to be some multiple, p,
of that translation.
p could be 0.
p could be 5.
But it has to be an integral
number of translations because
this translational periodicity
has to work everywhere,
including up on the top
of this trapezohedron.
So that's a constraint.
This angle is alpha.
We cannot let alpha be arbitrary
because the only way
we can add a rotation operation
A alpha to a lattice
is for a value of alpha which
makes this translation be a
multiple of the original one.
Now, let me take this geometry,
and I'm going to
extract the basic constraint
from it.
This is some integer, p times T.
This is T. This is T. This
is T. This is alpha.
Let me lickety split drop down
a perpendicular to the
original translation.
This is T times the
cosine of alpha.
This total length is T. This
length in here is p times T.
And now I can go away from the
geometry to an equation,
something you probably
prefer to deal with.
And what this constraint is
expressed analytically is that
my original translation, T,
minus twice T times the cosine
of alpha has to come out equal
to an integer, p times T. And
there's my constraint.
Alpha has to satisfy
that condition.
Well, I can immediately cancel
the T and write this as one
minus 2 cosine of alpha is
equal to an integer, p.
And it figures that that has to
be the case because none of
this construction depends on
the size of the original
translation that I took.
And now, let me solve for the
values of alpha which are
compatible with a lattice.
This says that cosine of alpha
is 1 minus p over 2.
And unless that condition
holds, my combination is
incompatible.
So I'm going to let that stew
with you until next time.
But what we've set up is
something where we can just
plug and chug, put in different
values of p.
And if I start out with a value
of p, and let's let p be
equal to 4, and then find one
minus p over 2, which is
supposedly the cosine
of an angle, alpha.
If that's 4, I will
have minus 3/2.
And the value of alpha obviously
does not exist.
Cosine of alpha cannot
get greater than 1.
If p is equal to 3, then 1 minus
3 over 2 is minus 2 over
2, or minus 1.
You like the way I do that
arithmetic in my
head just like that?
And the angle whose cosine is
minus 1 is 180 degrees.
And what that says is that
a two-fold axis works.
So I can drop a two-fold
axis into a net.
And what that's going to do is
take my original translation,
rotate it 180 degrees, and
the second translation is
going to sit here.
Rotate it 180 degrees in the
reverse direction, and then
the second lattice
point sits here.
And lo and behold, just as
advertised, the distance
between the first lattice point
and the final lattice
point is three translations.
So I can put a two-fold axis
in any lattice whatsoever
because this is compatible
simply with a lattice row.
So one possible combination of
rotation in a lattice is going
to be any lattice whatsoever,
and what we can add to this is
a rotation operation A pi.
And we'll have two full rotation
operations which are
translationally equivalent.
All right.
Several integers to go.
We would want to
try p equals 2.
That's going to work.
p equals plus 1 is
going to work.
p equals 0 is going to work.
And we will find a very limited
number of rotational
operations that are compatible
with a lattice.
And this is going to give us a
small number of the possible
combinations of lattice and
rotational symmetry in two
dimensions.
So we'll pick up from there
next time, and we'll very
quickly determine the remaining
possibilities and
take a look at what the
arrangement of symmetry
elements look like in
these lattices.
OK, once again, I have some
extra copies of the syllabus
if somebody did not get one.
And I'll have extra copies
of the problem set.